this week brings with it alien isolation
a game where you spend the vast majority
of your time trying not to get gobbled
up by the horrifying solitary alien
stalking you everywhere you go
if you're a horror game fanatic or a
masochist video games are just the place
to be if you're looking to replicate the
experience past alien isolation video
games are just filled with the kind of
monsters perfectly designed to keep you
up at night staring into the shadows
just in case I've collected five enemies
so I'd really not like to meet in a dark
alleyway or a light alleyway or just
anywhere ever
now unfortunately I've only got five
spots to give out and there are so many
really good picks the speedy and
threatening tyrants and liqueurs from
Resident Evil the blue ice shibito of
siren doom threes cherubs Pyramid Head
who I've spent a good time discussing
before and the headcrabs from half-life
are all very effective at eliciting
those fear riddled feelings be sure to
let me know if I've left out your pick
for freakiest video game monster but for
the moment here's 5 of mine what could
possibly be scary in a game that's
already chucked to the brim with zombies
well oddly enough it's the chick hanging
out in the corner of the map leaving you
alone and crying said game is left 4
dead 2 and said chick is the witch which
is one of the special infected but
unlike the others she only attacks when
provoked usually by you moving too close
to her or by using a flashlight at night
she sits waiting in one spot while in
the daytime you can find her wondering
should you startle her she launches at
the offending party with a bloody mouth
full of teeth and 12 inch claws four
fingers only ceasing the attack when
either she or the victim dies and it's
usually the victim who goes down first
should she win she runs off sobbing
ready to scare the crap out of you later
with her signature screech
don't startle the goddamn witch there's
a special fear reserved for the enemies
that scared she was a child and for me
the sound of this one is still hugely
disconcerting Marie dad's might have a
semi stupid name but when they first
popped up in ocarina of time they proved
the bassam BS beasty with powers of
paralysis by any other name would be as
scary that persistent droning coupled
with a chilling scream when link gets
too close is a pretty solid memory for
kids that owned n64 not only that but if
you're in a tight vicinity the dudes
would paralyze you jump on your back and
bite at you while you mash the a and B
buttons trying to get away they're easy
enough to avoid but they're unnaturally
idle nature and drowning urns though a
place on this list number three on my
list was encountered Wells Arena and I
played through the ghost heavy fatal
frame - pretty much every encounter in
Fatal Frame 2 was totally terrifying but
as it happens not all horrifying ghosty
attacks are made equal some way into the
game whilst rummaging for shiny items
you encounter a room with a box
unluckily the box house a particularly
creepy ghost aptly named woman in box
her attack pattern consisted of
stumbling slowly toward the player with
her long hair pulled over like the girl
from the ring before revealing a freaky
face and launching full-speed for a
final grapple which unfortunately is
pretty much the only ton you can snap a
photo of her to deal a chunk of damage
my second-to-last pic also happens to
come from the Zelda series but I
maintain that it is a damn terrifying
universe with no monstrous creepy as
wall masters I took on a link between
worlds on 3ds recently and was
unfortunate enough to encounter these
bastards yet again the big C's are just
floating hands that threaten you with a
growing shadow of a link before swatting
you from above
they're also known to crawl along the
ground grab it link and do all the
things at hands do but in a gigantic
violent form frustratingly if they grab
you they're also known to drag you all
the way back to the start of a dungeon
and ability I think we all lost our
patience with pretty quickly the little
ones are bad enough but link between
worlds up the stakes with it's knuckle
muster boss a giant a giant hand with a
freaky giant eye in the middle
still with the sweating and punching and
pushing and all sorts of attacks that
are frustratingly difficult to dodge not
a lot of things make your heart sink as
fast in a Zelda game as an eerie shadow
settling of a link in the middle of a
dungeon and the super freaky enemies
that have me avoiding an entire corner
of gaming are inevitably the gatherers
from amnesia if you're lucky you
probably don't know what these guys look
like and that's because they haven't
gotten all up in your face before
murdering you brutally if you're
anything like me this is the point we've
submitted to running frantically or just
letting go of the mouse to watch your
protagonist get slashed to death by the
empty eyed malformed buggers this is the
only entry of mine where the game
doesn't let you fight back at all
run and hide are your only options and
keeping your eye on the monsters low as
your character's sanity inevitably this
makes the gatherers way more terrifying
you spend the entirety of amnesia being
stalked by them and it's freaking awful
particularly in the prison although the
invisible water monster who chumps you
to bits as soon as you're submerged
really gives the gather as a run for
their money even though it appears very
briefly that particular monster has also
subsequently made every water section of
every game hugely terrifying for me
case in point with when I played the
amnesia prequel penumbra Black Plague
let me know down in the comments who you
reckon deserves the title of most
terrifying character in gaming and I
will catch you next week